Okay, so if you're like me you've already glanced
at the duration of this video and are thinking this
is way too long. Don't worry. You don't have to
watch the entire thing. What we are going to do
in this video is work together to download Python. Now, downloading
a computer language can sometimes be a frustrating process. So what I'm going to
do is Go slow, and identify all of the steps in detail. By the
way, if you already have Python, feel free to skip this
video and move on to the next lesson. Also if you
prefer to read the instructions on how to download Python. There
are a few helpful documents in the Instruction Notes section. Those
documents will walk you through the exact same process that we
are following in this video. Okay, now I'm going to start
the download process on a Windows machine. If you're on a
Mac, click here to jump ahead in the video. Okay, so here
I am on a Windows machine where I will
google download Python. The first result looks good to me.
You will notice that Python has two main versions.
We will use Version 2.7 in this course. By the
way, the link to this page is also available
in the instructor notes. Now, this page may look slightly
different than the one you have open on your computer.
That's okay, I want you to find the features that
are similar between this page and the one that you
may have open on your computer. If you scroll down on
this page, you will notice that there are a bunch
of links. Now, the first link here will help us download
Python on Windows. Notice that depending on your internet speed,
this download may take a while. One the file has downloaded
I can click to run it. This will launch a
wizard which I will go through. I will choose the default
python directory under the C drive and then I will continue to hit next a few
times. And boom, very quickly the installation will
be done. Now to test if Python installed
correctly I can go to the Start Menu,
hit All Programs, find Python 2.7, which is
what we just installed and launch Idle. Idle
is the place where we can write Python programs.
So let's write a few programs in Idle like 2 plus 2 That seemed to work. And
print yay python. All right, congratulations. You can skip
the rest of this video and move on to
the next lesson now. Okay, so here I'm on a Mac. Now, the first thing I will do
is figure out the version of my Mac. It
seems mine is 10.7, yours may be different. Next
I will Google download Python. The first result here
seems good to me. You will notice that Python
has two main versions. We will use version 2.7
in this course. By the way The link to
this page is also available in the instructor notes.
Now this page may look slightly different than the
one you have open on your computer. That's okay,
I want you to find features that are similar
between this page and the one you may have open on your computer. Now if you
scroll down on this page you will notice a bunch of links. The first few
download links are for windows. So we can safely ignore them. The next two links
are for mac. The first of those links is for mac 10.6 or later. Now
since my mac was 10.7 this is the right link for me. If you have
a version of Mac that came before 10.6 you
should use the other link. So, I will click
to download python. Note, that depending on your internet
speed, this download may take a while. Once Python
has downloaded, I will run the downloaded file. I
will click on this Python file while holding down
the Ctrl key and then click Open. This will
start the wizard. Here, I can hit Continue a few
times to install Python. And boom, the installation
is done. Now, to test if Python was
installed correctly, I will go Spotlight and then
type idle. Idle is the place where we
can write Python programs. Here I will hit
enter to get the python prompt and then
write a few really quick programs like 2
plus 2 that seemed to work and print yay
python alright congratulations you are now ready to move on to the next lesson.